Hello everybody.
Hi Minto!
Howdy!
Howdy dudey!
Ciao!
Wow!
Hi everybody, welcome in!
Welcome in!
I would chat, chit chat for a little bit.
I did have to start stream a little bit later though than
usual because I was at a meet and greet for Animathon.
I had a meet and greet at animathon.
Tomorrow we have a concert, very exciting, Densetsu.
That's EXE concert.
And uh, but the meet and greet ran over a little, little
more than I expected.
Which is a-okay.
We, we're just yapping ladies.
And uh, uh, I wanted to give myself a little extra time to
eat.
So, I was a little bit late.
But also, today is my fellow Densetsu.exe member Victoria
Roman, it's her birthday and outfit reveal so when she
starts stream I wanna I wanna I wanna Ibu rush into there so
today's stream will be a little bit shorter than usual but
we're gonna be grooving we're gonna be smooving we're gonna
be Drifting With our trains We got Den Shatak Let's go!
Worldwide Minto
Shmoven and grooving Yeah, everybody will say it Will wish
Vicky a super duper happy birthday And she has a really fun
outfit reveal So Her outfit is so cute Hello Minto and I was
like you Looking real cute and cool today Hope you had lots
of fun at anime I did it!
I love meet and greet so much.
They're so fun.
Getting lots of...
Lots of...
Old faces, new faces.
That's great.
Multi-track drifting.
Masaka!
Shona!
Happy International Cat Day.
Is it really?
Meow.
I cannot describe how fun this game has been.
I really hope you enjoy it.
Thank you!
I want to play as Limeu!
Limeu has a skin in the game, if I understand correctly.
So I want to play Limeu's skin.
I want Limeu's skin.
Limeu, give me your skin.
Mint is always a pleasure to me.
Yeah!
Really?
Thank you for taking us on a train ride before the big
birthday party.
Of course!
We get a whole day.
day oh cats take up thank you hi aminto can't wait to see
you grooving and schmoving on the train oh yeah thank you
thank you thank you I accidentally started the stream with
normal latency so there may be a bit of a delay between me
and chat this time I'm so sorry I apologize but uh yeah my
bad my bad my setup okay oh yeah all good all good all good
met you three times it's a treat every time you're not sick
of me right you're not gonna i worry when i see people too
much if i what if you what if you get sick of me What if?
What if?
We could wait 40 seconds for your reply.
You're digging the music.
Me too.
It's very...
Funky.
I'm a fan.
Never!
Okay, I'm trusting you guys.
Anxiety minto.
I have two modes.
Small anxiety.
and biggest anxiety.
Actually, it's not even small.
Regular anxiety and biggest anxiety.
That's my two modes.
I'm already stressing about what to say next time.
You just have to come in with your...
When you came in before resting glitch face, you were all
smiles.
And then you showed us the resting face.
But...
stone cold same here it's average my anxiety average or huge
Minto has two wolves inside her both have anxiety yeah oh so
let's Let's attack, baby.
This is my first time playing this, obviously.
Actually, I haven't even seen so much footage of it either.
Like, I saw when it came out and people were talking about
it.
And just a little bit.
It's hard not to smile when there's me, though.
But I'll do my best.
Yeah.
Build, welcome back.
Thank you so much.
She attack and she protect.
Do I protect?
Only attack, only attack.
No defense.
This is my favorite kind of way to play is only offense,
only attack.
Who needs good...
Japan.
Future, Japan.
...has pushed humanity into air purifying dome cities.
Oh.
A future not so distant from yours.
That's concerning.
Don't say that.
Miraido.
...has connected the country through an underground network
of supersonic railway systems.
High-tech cities have become crowded.
Oh.
Whole of families pursuing a better life.
But really, who cares about all that?
YouTube canceled my membership.
No!
Oh, thank you for coming back.
I appreciate it.
This is a story about outlaws.
Outlaws.
Vandals.
Oh, yeah.
About those who remain outside.
It doesn't look so bad.
out here what's so bad about it um outside japan buenos
noches buenos noches emmy's awakening
we got a hot ramen delivery
happy ramen well no time to waste all right press a to start
start your engine Oh, do I have to hold it?
Okay, yes.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
LT, it's a break.
Oh, okay.
To avoid dangers.
It just goes automatically.
Drift?
By breaking.
Hold drift.
when the bar appears.
And release on the sweet spot in the center of the...
Alright, nice.
Don't hold A.
Oh.
Wait.
Did I get it right?
Oh, I don't think so.
Wait, I don't know if I'm doing this right.
Dorifto!
that seems correct okay they weren't kidding that sweet
sweet middle spot I love tasting green that's why green is
the best baby when tracks split choose direction with okay
remember you'll still need to drift around the bends right
oh ah let me try that again You have to hold it?
Oh!
Be net!
Oh my gosh, it's so fun!
Oh!
Switch to a neighboring track with L.
Okay.
Fukura!
Thanks for the gifted!
The soundtrack is awesome!
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Hooray!
Hold and release RT to jump.
A spark will appear when the jump is fully charged.
Oh, like that!
Oh, oh, geez.
Hooray!
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, I had to!
I probably should have...
Oh, shoot.
Oh, wait.
I forget that I need to charge it up.
Okay, okay, okay.
We're good, we're good, we're good, we're good, we're good.
Hoi!
Jump RT and then switch to a neighboring track.
Airborne.
Whoa!
Nice?
Oh.
That was close.
Oh, ah, oh, ah!
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Tutorial.
So easy.
Oh.
Tutorial so easy.
Ina.
Wall in the air, stomp to the ground.
Dodge under tall obstacles.
Oh, okay.
Whoa, okay, okay.
Oh.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Ah!
There we go.
Did I mark it?
Hello!
You're delivered, your Uber is here.
This is how trains work, obviously.
I've been on every train, every train I've been like.
The ramen is...
Thank you for your patronage.
Wait, your train driving skills are out of this world.
Are you a Dench attacker?
Dench attacker?
What now?
Like, holy forehead on this girl.
You don't know about Dench attack?
The most skilled drivers in Japan compete against each other
doing tricks and races.
attack is that really a thing yes you've got to try it
imagine the ramen in there is probably like shaken and right
now stirred and everything baby color thanks for that gift
dude Andrea welcome back you've been on every train oh yeah
okay tell me how to get cool this dentsh attack thing.
You're already pretty cool, but you definitely need tricks.
Huh?
Tricks?
Yeah, this is a train calibration station.
Dentsh attackers use it to practice their stunts.
They try stuff like flipping your machine in mid-air before
falling back on the track.
I see, like this.
Oh,
I didn't even wait, I didn't...
I just flew.
We're pouring chicks in the air.
Oh, by moving.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
All the passengers are goners, Vito.
They turn to mince me.
It's just me, baby.
It's funny because it looks like a school bus more than a
train sometimes.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my gosh.
Is this a secret?
fighting game wait oh my god here's some other tricks i
think i did it trictionary find a collection of all the
tricks in the trictionary holy front 180 impossible finger
olly who's fingering my olly the names phantom and phantom i
take my ramen shaken, not slurred.
Now try to pull as many tricks as you can on this circuit.
Okay.
Oh.
Well, my bad.
Oh, I did one.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, yeah.
I'm doing, I'm doing the crazy.
I'm doing everything crazy.
You never, you never know.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, shoot.
Oh, shoot, wait.
Nice.
Oh, that wasn't one.
Oh, yes, it was.
Nice, too.
How many do you need?
Oh, oh, I did it again.
Nice, too.
Did I make it?
The last four-star one was actually really good.
Thanks!
I know exactly what I did.
I got shivers on my spine!
Does the lill-l-l-l-ing during tricks give you extra points?
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
You're the real deal.
Oh, wait, what's your name?
Phantom.
Mint Phantom.
You're damn right.
I'm Emmy Araki!
My name is Fernando Tamashiro.
I'm a freelance photographer.
Nice to meet you, Araki-san.
Drop the formalities, Fer.
If someone...
If my name was Fernando and someone just called me Fer, at
least call me the Nando.
I don't know.
Hey, Fer.
Call...
Everyone calls me Emmy.
Fur?
Come on, I want to try a real dentsy attack course now.
You'll take me, right?
Hey, me.
Fur.
Rumor has it that sounding like a turkey while doing tricks
makes them better.
Like, it does!
Fair?
Fernando?
Fur?
Whoa!
Wait, I want to look around a little.
Can I look around?
It won't let me move.
Oh, yeah, there we go.
Hot ramen delivery.
Hot ramen delivery is in your area.
Oh, that's what I just did.
Okay, it makes sense.
Adventure awaits.
Fern?
Fern would be better even.
Fern.
You hear that, Zach?
What's in my garage?
I want to change the color.
Customize.
Wait.
This one is perfect for me.
This one, this one.
Stickers!
Wait, cute!
Oh, so cute.
Milk.
Oh my god, this is so cool looking.
This is awesome.
But I kinda...
Even what?
What's colors?
Oh.
I wish they had like a pink.
That looks great though.
Wow, that looks good, that looks good.
We'll go with the mint though.
Now I feel really inspired.
We're the Bepu star.
An old but balanced train.
Prepare for any situation.
Bepu, Bepu, Bepu, Bepu, Bepu, Bepu.
6,000 next rank.
no crash finish smashed two wooden bridges scare oh I forgot
I can honk and stuff scare the bats in the cave trick over
the moai heads perform five perfect drifts easy please let
this be a normal train ride with the me though no way what's
up fan toe but isn't that pink anyway
Whoa, I got a trick over to Muay
This is a pretty standard Dench attack course Seems like
there's no one around right now Bummer No, it's a perfect
opportunity to get the basics down I agree, I need more
practice Yeah, the soundtrack is so fun, no?
Let me know how the The sound balancing is a little tricky
because the voices are quite low, but the music is quite
high.
I actually didn't do any here.
The sound stuff before stream.
Tense attacking isn't just about being cool.
You also need to be fast.
You need to reach the goal on time with at least a minimum
amount of points.
Points?
Points are calculated by...
Wait, wait, wait.
I just want to have fun.
You do the counting.
It'll be my pleasure.
I happen to be quite knowledgeable.
about the scoring system.
Alright, check this out.
3, 2, 1, go!
Wooah!
Nice!
Oh, oh!
Oh shoot.
Did I take damage from that?
Nice there.
Whoa!
Oh, that was close.
Oh, maybe it should have, uh, Whoa!
Maybe I should have scared the...
Wait, what is that?
I missed something over there.
Whoa!
Oh, oopsie.
I did scare the bats though.
Where?
Oh, here we go.
To the left.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Nice, Sue.
Whoa!
Wait, my bad.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Oh, nope.
Wait!
Wait, what am I doing wrong?
Do tricks.
I will!
We're fine.
Wait!
Oh!
Because I wasn't actually switching, I was doing the trick
thing, my bud.
There we go, okay, hold on.
I'm getting it, I'm getting it.
There we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Whoa!
Oh, I have to switch.
Wait, don't I have to switch?
Or do I hop here?
I hop here?
Oh, oh, there we go, there we go, there we go.
It's the thing that I always forget to do.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Okay, okay.
Oh my gosh.
I don't like that it puts me right here.
Okay, okay, okay, we're good.
We're good, we're good.
We're good.
This way?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, this way?
Okay, we
got this.
Yeah.
Go, go, go, go!
I know I'm not used to jumping.
I got to float, right?
Come on, go, go, go, go, go.
There we go.
Oh, nice.
Oh.
Oh, jump jump!
I'm so bad with jumping!
Okay, here we go.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
We're fine.
Oh, we're fine.
We'll get him next time.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
It doesn't mean they're coming up.
Oh, slam down!
Not yet.
Don't trigger me to do it.
And then if you don't mean it, don't trigger me to do it.
Slam in the middle.
Oh, I should have, right?
Oh, you're so right.
I got barely anything.
I didn't do very many tricks, huh?
Smash two wooden bridges.
No crash finish.
Oh, you're supposed to not crash into the sign.
Wait, can I do it again?
I got a...
Well...
Let's try it again.
Yeah, I'm still learning.
Oh, that was only good.
They won a second.
Oh, that was, was that the second one?
Did I miss it already?
Oh, shoot.
Oh,
that was so close.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Okay.
Oh, step up!
Okay, okay.
Oh, wait, I didn't mean to go this way!
Oopsie.
Oh, wait, wait,
wait.
Oh, wait.
Oh, we'll get him next time.
Yeah, yeah, we'll get him next time.
You're so right.
right buddy I forgot where it put me up
only good there okay I'm gonna I'm gonna wham bam down there
here we go grab
your first film roll Oh, look how much better I did!
I can see how people get addicted to this.
There was the second wooden bridge I saw that had the spray
can.
But for now, we'll continue onward.
I'll accept this for now.
How is that?
Impressive for a first timer.
The bridge comes up so fast!
The second one.
Yeah.
No crash finishes means no restarts.
Oh, I thought it was the actual ending.
Oh, no, I crashed several times.
Hey, for a first timer?
I mean, you can always do better.
That's one of the many beauties of Dench Attack.
I want to be better.
Take me to some real Dench Attack battles.
Okay, let's go.
Wait, am I ready?
Very arcade-y.
Yeah, that's a great way to put it.
This is just the start.
It gets insane.
Who's the best Dench Attacker around here?
feels like a rhythm game where you have to like I mean they
encourage you to play it multiple times because there's no
way you're gonna be able to get everything the first time
but feels like a rhythm game and that like you kind of have
to memorize the the tracks and everything that'd be Yoshi's
Oh Yoshi is a high school dropout from a wealthy family
she's only interested in partying fashion and spending her
parents money
yeah by the show yeah by the show sounds like a real
character hey this magazine is super cool you don't do you
like it it's a dentsia tack fanzy and I'm editing myself
this guy's such a fanboy I want to read more she's a gyaru
Well, I'm still putting it together.
I tell you what, help me take great photos by performing
tricks on these circuits.
And I'll share all my intel with you.
Deal, okay, let's go challenge Yoshi.
Well, Yoshi is in Fukuoka and she's gathered quite a
notorious gang.
We're bound to face some of her Kogals controlling the area.
Not the Kogals!
Oh, no problem.
Just point me in the right direction.
Emmy is thirsty for blood.
Dang, we went all the way.
We're heading down.
I got some new spray paints, right?
So...
Oh.
Just kidding.
Hmm.
Are they patterns?
No.
Are they stickers?
What are the spray paint?
Sprite cans.
I didn't realize till now, but you could land a plane on
Emmy's brows.
I noticed it, too.
I'm not going to lie.
No crash finish.
Okay, I can do that.
Stomp on the sand castle.
Smash 10 satellite antennas.
Okay, we got to be jump, jump, jumping.
Perform three different tricks in a row.
Risky Dodgers.
Why does Emmy design remind me of Barrybug?
Oh, I see it.
The sprays are a currency for later.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Sea size showdown.
Dang, she controls the place.
Have you guys ever been to Fukuoka?
I've only gone once, but it's very nice when I went.
Wait, I want...
I want the cat train!
Hmm, who let this fashion disaster walk onto our tracks?
No crash, yeah, Mint got it.
Yeah, don't you trust me?
I'm going to challenge Yoshi to a dance attack duel.
How sweet.
I won't let you.
Especially now looking like that.
Yoshi will be scarred for life if she had to witness a yard
of it.
Well, tough luck, I wasn't asking for your permission.
Cute, you're on.
Show me what you've got.
Maddie?
Whoa.
Oh.
Oh no, I wasn't fast enough.
Whoa!
Nice.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
I'm so good at tricks!
Oh!
Wait!
It's okay.
I was able to get those now.
No!
I missed it!
Who's called?
Oh!
Oh, oh, shoot.
It's every time, you guys.
Nice.
Oh, I
already got it.
That's why.
Okay, we're fine.
Oh.
And it's nice.
Oh, bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl- Habunese, she says.
Bal-unese, bal-unese.
I'm talking about pasta.
Sorry.
Wait, how?
How do I turn again?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, that was close.
Nice.
Oh, I should have used that one as a...
As, like, a...
Perform a...
Oh, wait.
Ah!
Oh, I see.
Oh,
come on.
Okay, no doing tricks, no doing tricks.
Only avoiding.
It didn't even let me jump, so it's okay.
Whoa.
Nice.
Yippa!
I did...
Wow!
Oh.
Stomp on the sand castle.
Hot magma.
Hot digity magma.
Here we go!
Actually, my outfit is perfect for a seaside showdown.
Ooh, we're staying cool this summer.
Let's try again.
I got out.
I don't know what rank that is.
I think the sandcastle was right at the star.
Okay, let's try it one more time.
It was right at the star.
I don't even think I saw it.
Oh, right there.
Oh.
I crashed.
Did I get it?
Oh, oops, wrong one.
Oh, oops, wrong thing.
Or, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Woof.
Abunese.
Balunese.
That's what they all say.
Sayza!
Oh!
Oh, that was just okay.
Oh, we'll get him next time, he says.
What a dodge.
Wait, I already got this one, so...
Oh, yeah.
Check this out.
Oh, I got it!
Oh, my son!
Yeah, that's what they all say.
Oh, jump!
Did I get this one?
Oh no I did already didn't I?
Ah!
Oops.
We'll stay on the, we'll stay on the regular path then.
Cause I'm curious.
Oh shoot.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yummy.
That's, that's not the way I wanted to go, but that's okay.
I go to the left and it takes me to the right.
Yeah.
I forgot to do it the last time, but I did it this time.
The risky dodge, a risky dodge, a risky dodge, a risky
dodge.
Oh, I did the five risky dodgers.
We are too good.
It's
giving me the option, so I wanted to go to the lift.
No crash finish.
Dang, I got six out of seven.
I got silver theirs.
We keep going.
Bronze.
Smoking turkey style.
Don't say it.
Don't stop saying it, you guys.
You're not half bad.
I have to admit that stunt with the Ferris wheel guard can't
be completely off guard.
But I can't in good conscience let you challenge the Yoshi
without barring ass train.
Speed is transitory.
Style is eternal.
There's a band of artists and engineers occupying Kumamoto
Castle.
Go there and get your train in proper than shatakshai.
Please keep saying it.
Oh, we're getting the...
We're getting the...
Oh, this is...
This is how I'll become the best.
This place is so cool.
Kauru!
Wait, I realize you guys can't really see.
Hold on.
I'll go a bit smaller.
There we go.
Should be better.
We need more nasal.
We do.
Hello.
Hey, is that train yours?
Yes, I used to deliver ramen, but now I'm getting into Dench
Attack.
Someone recommended that I come here for a glow up.
That machine is quite old, but it seems like you take good
care of it.
I always root for the newbie.
It'd be an honor to work on your train.
This game is just dripping in style.
I know.
Regional gangs.
Oh my god.
I don't even know her.
I don't even know you.
And I'm just gonna spray paint you on my car.
It was a regional.
Oh cute!
General.
Wait, so cute!
I like that one.
What's the one that's that's below?
This is where you can unlock Lymu.
Wait, where?
You need a code for Lymu skin oh I didn't do anything I
never imagine my train could look this cool thanks so much
oops if you want a fresh look collect spray cans on the
circuits then you'll we'll use them to create new art we
tend to hang out in castles look out for them if you travel
to other regions oh wait it's an actual like D-Pod code.
Okay, hold on.
Whoa!
Wait, where is she?
Gangs?
Regional?
General?
Wait, I unlocked her.
Wait, I took her.
Wait.
I sent you the code in the work server earlier.
I wasn't paying attention.
Wait, where is it?
Where is she?
garage on the world map oh garage oh my bad
we'll do like this one wait it looks really good with the
blue though hmm hold on
Yeah, I want her as my announcer too.
I want her as my announcer.
Lime!
Uh, wait.
Do I...
How do I get her though?
Or, uh...
Do I have to like go back to the main manual?
Main manual.
Oh, oops.
There we go.
Uh...
Audio?
Oh
Japanese so cute though Yay, okay Cute Yay, okay
Okay, never change our voice, our train ever again.
Though, I'm still...
I think I liked the blue after all.
Okay, what do we hear?
Knock over the boxes, trick while breaking a window, perform
a back 360 kick.
Score over 100 points on a single grind.
sweet spot.
That's my sister.
Lime language.
Wait, if I did, if I had a voice in the game, and then I'm
just like minto language.
Where are we?
This is one of Mirai-do's lemonade factories.
Whoa.
I love Mirai Yuzu, sparkling Ramune.
Don't let anyone else hear about that.
All Dench attackers loathe the Mirai Do Corporation.
Oh, wow.
It controls the dome cities and is slowly claiming the
abandoned railways to develop its AI operated train system.
No!
Why are we here then?
This factory happens to be the ideal spot to learn about
grinding.
Why don't we destroy it instead?
So true.
Announce your comments?
Wait, that's what I did, no?
Yeah, I have announce your comments on.
I already did that.
Wait, you're serious?
Don't worry, I'll learn how to grind while I'm at it.
Let's go.
Wait, we're destroying it?
The train will grind on lone rails.
Tap L in the right direction to keep your center balance.
Okay, time to learn.
Go!
Oh.
Wait, could I have grinded on that?
That's dirty game.
That's dirty.
That was dirty.
I'm still learning.
learning game oh yeah you you you how dare you put my
greatest nemesis oh you you you you oh you let me try that
again oh you you you you you you wait how far out am I oh
it's literally always the jumps that get me quite literally
every Oh, ah!
They're my kryptonite truly ugly.
Yo yo yo yo yo yo yo.
Don't lower your guard, Ami.
I'm trying!
I keep missing, I missed every single one.
Okay, we're definitely gonna do this again.
Don't worry.
Track designed to make you crash.
Ain't not bad though.
I guess maybe.
I forgot to perform the back 360 kick.
Oh, yo, yo, yo, yo.
My chat is over.
The chat is all oi oi yoi yoi yoi.
I can't help what sounds I make you guys.
I truly cannot.
Everything just comes out naturally.
I got an uva.
Alright let's do that again for Schiller.
Hoi!
Yep!
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh
Okay here it's coming up it's coming up Oh, oh, yo.
Oh, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Did I do it?
No, that was a friend, huh?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
How am I supposed to get that up there?
Just like that.
Oh,
I got another one.
Let's go.
Wait,
without crashing!
I did it!
I did crash!
Please
work!
Don't forget to way your way to victory, everybody.
What did I get?
An ua!
Ua and bronze.
Okay, I'll accept that.
She's goaded?
Always has been.
Ah, now I'm pumped.
That one more.
We're still a long way from Fukuoka.
We're going to have to take a detour to find a way there.
What?
No detours.
Let's go across the sea.
Across the sea?
Come on, it'll be fun.
Get on board.
No misses, Minto Gaming.
You gotta, you gotta, you gotta.
You gotta.
Minto love.
JMAX, thank you!
Lime luck.
You're so right.
I didn't hear her though.
Maybe I was oi oiing too much.
I think I was...
I think I was oi oi oiing too much.
You can send Lime to comment whenever you land a trick.
Didn't I do that, though?
Wait!
Oh, I could have gone straight.
Oh,
my gosh.
That was...
Oh, ouch.
Wait, there we go.
Oh, god!
Oh, oops.
Did I make it?
Oh, what?
I definitely... I definitely clicked left there, but...
Wait.
Oh, hey?
It showed something.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, oh, yo, yo.
Oh.
Oh, oops, oops.
Oh, yeah.
No crashing.
Don't do it.
No.
Not this time.
Oh shoot!
Whoa, I was wobbling off the...
Nice.
Hoi!
Oh, we're in the water now.
It's fine, that's fine.
Whoa!
Hoi!
Yeah.
Oh, wait, when did this happen?
How did this happen?
Oh my god!
Check that out.
Yeah, baby.
Whoa!
There we go.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah!
Whoa!
Oh!
Oh, Triquel on the thing!
Yeah!
Oh, boats are just trains in disguise.
The whole ship, baby.
Dang!
Air stomp on the Zeppelin.
Oh, I didn't...
where was that 500 points from grind sweet spots holy i like
doing each one twice hold on i gotta i gotta keep track of
the time too okay we're perfectly fine okay we still have a
oh no wait i accidentally clicked continue instead of we do
it again actually let's just keep going i want to play as
much as i can emmy you're out of this world a deal about
sharing my intel if you get if you got me some great photos
i've gathered together a draft that's ready to go to print
there's an independent press around here they call
themselves
enzyme enzyme you might have turned off most of limo's
commentary wait but it was regular for the other thing
people think it was an iceberg that took out the titanic but
it was really just a poorly timed backfliped 360.
why don't you come come with me and I'll show you.
It'll come in handy now that you're closer to challenging
Yoshi's.
Wait, but it was normal before.
Announce your comments on.
Is it this?
Mute on focus lost?
I turned that off.
Chat says you can up the Limu chat in settings.
I know, I know, but nobody's telling me how.
Announce your comments to extended Oh, okay, okay.
Do I...
Should I do this, though?
The mute on focus, Lars?
Yeah, delayed chat.
Sorry, guys.
It is not very...
Yeah, it's kind of unintuitive.
Yeah, just a little bit.
You can pump up the announcer audio, too.
Yeah, we'll try it.
We'll set her to, like, 70.
That mutes the game when you click off.
Ah!
I want this off then for sure because it annoys the heck out
of me when games do that.
Announce your comments more on.
Yep.
Thank you.
Thank you, Valkyrie.
We're good now.
Oh, cute.
Puddy-Kun.
Welcome.
How can I help you?
Oh, my God.
Yoshi, she vandaled him.
Is this an original?
autonomous printing station that's right you can call me
pretty good but he can you're so cute thank you last time I
was in Japan they were only just starting to deploy these
and never managed to see one in person the plan is for
anyone in Japan to be able to become a part of an
independent work network of artists by uploading and
printing fanzines at any end zine HQ that's That's right, is
there anything you'd like to publish?
You bet.
Dashing queens.
Oh, my queen.
Print?
Oh, oh, oh.
Whoa!
Rika!
She can come on strong, but Rika is actually quite friendly.
Rumor has it she's a bit of a furry wearing cat ears.
And a tail to represent her wild side.
Although she's the youngest member of the gang, she's...
She quickly became Yoshi's best friend thanks to the fire
she brings into any situation.
I think that's all I've got.
Oh wait, we have a bit more.
I lied.
We had...
Next page.
More?
Oh, this one!
Oh!
Ooh, the history!
Mawai.
During the period of isolationism in the 17th century,
Kyushu was Japan's engine more...
Give me more girls.
Active volcanoes.
Oh, donkots.
The BGM is very good, yeah.
Minto uncovering history.
priorities guys we're on limited time we gotta attack attack
attack I can't even read get ready was that limo I don't
know five pieces of chrystella yummy trick through a paint
balloon smash multi statue trick on five different vert
ramps perform three grind tricks I'll try
whoa is that the statue I have to break is that oh we're in
Nagasaki you're the one that beat Rika you don't look like
you don't look like much although your train is less hideous
than I expected given what she said about it speed is
transitory style is eternal I heard her loud and clear
Someday Minto will learn how to read, I believe.
Thank you.
Thank you for believing in me.
One day...
Kitty, kitty, kitty.
I want to pet the kitty.
One day I'll be able to read the kitty book.
Can Minto use a Gyaru voice?
I can try.
I'm not very gyaru.
Ersk at all.
My Oshi can't be this illiterate.
There may be some hope for you after all.
Want to join us?
It's just a valley girl.
I'm actually more interested in defeating Yoshio.
Masi!
Uke-er!
Wait.
You're serious?
Homa?
Trust me, she is.
And I believe Emmy can win.
You have no idea of what you're talking about.
Look, I don't care if you want to get stomped by Yashie, but
at least prove you're not going to waste your time.
This was once one of the biggest Densha-Tac circuits in all
of Kyushu.
But Mirai-Do has made its move and is trying to redevelop
this area.
Show us you can wreak some havoc.
You could destroy Mirai-Do's comms towers.
We destroyed the comms towers.
towers.
What?
Suddenly it's like Metal Gear.
Destroy their comms towers so they go so they can't
communicate.
Destroy their sheds so they go hungry.
Mess with their construction yards.
Also Nagasaki's old mining town is ugly as hell.
Somebody needs to burst paint all over it if you ask me.
That's what the paint is for.
It's time for crimes.
Then press us here, and I'll consider giving you a chance.
It'll be my pleasure.
Just watch me.
Game reminds me of Jet Set Radio in the best ways.
Yes, yes, yes for sure.
Complete all objectives around the map, then break to a stop
to finish the track.
Oh, fine.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
That's so awesome.
Go!
Oh.
Oh!
Decision time.
Oh, thanks, Lymu.
She's scared.
Oh.
All right, she says.
All right.
Whoa.
Left.
Thanks, Lymu.
I love you!
Oh, yeah, boy.
Yeah, boy, boy, boy.
You need to demolish four towers here.
Oh.
How do I demolish?
Ah!
Left?
Did I do it?
Oh, what was that?
Panic!
No panic!
Oh.
How do I destroy it?
Oh, yeah.
Thank you, Lymo.
Why doesn't she say right?
Nailed it!
You okay?
How
am I supposed to destroy this thing though?
Do I need to like...
Oh, I took it down!
Okay.
Oh, ah!
Yippee!
Oh,
shoot.
Yeah!
Okay.
Do I get it?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Very good.
Thank you.
Oh, ah!
I don't even know where it's put me... Oh, here we go.
That's what I get for trying to...
Ow!
We'll get him next time, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Nice.
I'm always doing the same trick I feel.
Yeah!
Lymu did not record going right.
Only going left.
Lymu is like...
Lymu is like, uh...
Zoo lander.
Very good.
Thank you.
I connected with Castella.
Okay, wait.
Oh, she did!
I heard her!
Yeah, I crashed into that guy.
Choose wisely.
Oh, uh, oh, ah!
Where am I supposed to go?
What'll it be?
I don't know!
I'm trapped!
on this loop no no no we're fine this is where i wanted to
go let's go floor star honk at the cranes to wreak some
chaos look hit
the lever
oh yeah uh yeah sweet sweet she said oh dang it i missed it.
Oh, is there?
Oh, I messed that up almost.
Where am I supposed to go now?
Let's try that again.
Yeah, try that again.
So now I go straight.
Okay.
And then which way?
Oh, we need to paint the town.
This way?
This way.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, sorry, I'm like, I was too busy concentrating.
Hitting!
Okay!
Oh, yo-yo-yo-yo!
Oh, yo-yo!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I messed up.
Oh, yo-y-yo.
Right!
okay I'm going right because Lyamu told me to oh left I'm
going left because Lyamu told me to yeah oh whoa oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah I'm so busy trying to
get these dang Don't forget to do attacks and tricks and
stuff.
Whoa!
Oh, sick!
Oh!
Yep.
I don't think I was finished there.
I completed all the objectives though.
I guess we're fine to break.
Right!
Oh.
Unless I want to get more points or something, but...
Nailed it.
Thank you.
Oh, there's other...
I completely missed it.
Not even close.
Oh, come on!
Limeo!
Limeo, please give me points!
Stop the train.
Yeah, I guess we'll just stop it here.
What if I...can I break on the...
Right!
Oh!
That's so unfair!
I was just breaking!
I wasn't even trying to do the thing!
Oh, wait, there we go.
Okay.
Nope.
We're good?
I hate it.
Did I do good?
Lymu, was I a good bench attacker?
You were average.
You were not the greatest.
You were...
I never doubted.
Yeah!
Because Lymu told me works in court.
It absolutely does, and don't let anyone tell you otherwise.
This brat might...
really breathe something.
Told ya.
What gang are you from?
I've taught you to do all that.
I'm on my own.
I've been using these trains for years.
My way.
When it comes down to it, Dench Attack isn't all that
different to delivering ramen.
Huh.
Interesting.
Don't underestimate Dench Attack.
We're not just having fun here.
This is our life.
Yeah.
This is my life.
I may just be starting out, but I'm taking this seriously.
I give my all to everything I do.
Okay, I'll give you a shot.
If you can defeat me, it's Saga.
Saga!
I'll take you to Yoshi and myself.
She's a bit of a furry, you guys.
Sorry, I was just...
I'm a method actress.
She's rabid.
Don't get me...
Get rabies, there's no cure.
And you don't end up like a crazy animal.
Small cat is looking at the screen going, what?
Saga!
You ready?
I don't know, Lyamu, are you ready?
Hey, Minto cool glasses.
Thank you.
Alright.
No crash finish.
Trick on all the vert ramps.
Does that mean like green ramps or what?
Scared the small temple pigeons.
Perform three perfect drifts in a row.
Find the onsen exit.
Okay.
Wow.
It's so pretty.
there's no one here are you sure this is the right place
wait i see a train coming if your limu will take york's job
as the gaming positive reinforcement voice in your head no
wait york i have zach in my head
right zach first are the ones that make you jump
automatically oh oh vertical ramps oh thank you thank you
Thank you.
We get a cutscene.
Did somebody order a diva?
Oh my god, it's a Yoshiai!
Masi!
So you're the one who's been making all the records.
Yoshiai!
In person!
Are you the leader of this gang?
Race me!
I love your energy, girl!
Let me do your makeup!
Me?
Yeah.
Zach is gone, only Lymo.
Yes, you have amazing features.
I could totally turn you into a goddess.
Yeah, check out the brows, baby.
Uh...
But I've come here to defeat you.
Oh.
Uh-huh.
Oh, she's not laughing, she's going, Boo,
I am employed again, thank you all for the previous good
energy.
Okay, back to multi-track, drifting.
Congratulations!
Sakun!
Aw, wow, wow, wow.
Aw, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow,
wow, wow.
Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da,
congrats.
Oh, I'm not here to win today.
Sorry, I was just curious about your beef with A, bro.
What's the tea, girlfriend?
That's right Eyes on the prize Kitty cat Sorry Sorry I had
some coffee before stream I think I think I'm not well
I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry Three super chats!
Dark noodles, thank you!
Spill the tea.
Keep it up!
If you can surprise April, I'll play with you.
I promise.
You pretty promise?
Coffee fun.
Keep going.
No, sorry.
Keep it up, kitty cat.
Never apologize for caffeinated feral.
Yeah, I've got zoomies right now, for real.
Realizing I need more caffeinated me, though.
You guys were enablers.
This is why I...
You get it for, like, a stream.
But if it was all the time this, you'd be like, oh, my God.
When will she stop growling?
And I'd be like, get her!
Gotcha.
You better start warming up then, Yoshi-y.
Or I'm gonna kiss you on that mouth.
She goes early.
Hooy, hooy, hooy.
Hooy, ooy, ooy.
That was too close.
Was it?
Oh, we only got an okay.
Oh, I only got an okay again.
Hooy!
Perfect.
Oh, yo, yo.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Oh, look out.
No!
Oh, shoot.
Wait, wait.
Wait.
Can I
get behind her?
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, yo, yo.
Oh, oh, oh.
We'll get him there, don't we?
Oh, that one was so close, though.
That one, like, it just warned me, like, crazy close.
Shmoving.
Oh, shmoving, baby.
Oh, yo, yo.
I'm always, oh, yo, yo, yo.
Oh gosh, it puts me all the way back here.
Where's the checkpoint?
Oh my gosh, every time.
Come on.
Oh man!
There we go, there we go.
Nice.
Okay.
Sweet!
Nah.
Yes!
Oh!
Oh, I should have jumped there!
Yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no, I didn't realize that was a drift.
I did not realize.
Oh, I still got it.
Let's go.
Oh.
My manual game.
My manual?
Is she flying?
Wait, what?
How do we do that?
Up or down when landing to ride on the front or back wheels.
No need to hold L once you land.
Okay.
Chain together tricks and manuals to increase your combo and
multiply your points.
What?
Very good.
Oh.
Wow.
Keep doing tricks, Evie.
You may be able to fly too.
I believe in you.
Ah!
I love you.
Wait.
Whoa!
We're like...
Whoa, we're not okay, I think.
Oh, shoot.
I'll take it.
My bad.
Let's go to the right this time.
That was definitely right, but sure, Lai Mu.
Whatever you say.
Ah!
Oh, from the very beginning, okay.
Right.
Yeah, there you go.
You got it right this time.
Don't lower your guard!
Oh my gosh, what the heck is this?
Ah!
There we go.
Wow!
This way.
Oh, boy!
Did the thing!
Rainbow Road!
Did we do good?
Did I do good?
I did find the onsen exit!
Unintentionally.
I did 4 out of 7, let's go.
We did fine.
Oh, that one didn't count.
I accept my fate.
We're fine.
We're not aiming for perfection here.
We're aiming for fun.
You're on fire, Emmy.
The next duel is against the Aeshe.
Uh.
Fur.
Boots with the fur.
Royal rainbow.
Smoke.
Limo even said I got smoke in sexy style.
That's like the top that you can get.
What were those magical roads?
that appeared at the end of our duel.
Rather good for a first run.
Those are the Yao Yoro Zudo.
Yao Yoro Zudo, the 8th million roads.
When Densh attackers get in the zone, they can perceive the
magnetic currents that fractured across the world after the
climate catastrophe.
Are we okay?
Paranoid, paranoia, welcome back!
With enough skill you can flow through them.
That's so cool!
I want to see them again!
Are we okay?
You will!
From now on, every time your combo meter is maxed out,
you'll enter the zone!
Tense attack!
Why don't we go in practice right now if you want to see the
Yao Yoruzudo again?
that will be important for your upcoming battle against
Yoshi.
Dance attack!
Ha?
Wait, is the onsen!
What is this?
Is this because we got the onsen?
Oh, experience your first onsen.
Talk about...
Emmy, where did you get your train?
Hmm.
Ah!
Oh my god, I'm so glad I'm censoring.
Oh my god.
Why is this a mixed bath?
Why is it a mixed bath?
I mean, your train is quite a peculiar model.
Where did you get it?
I think I have train drama.
I mean, brain drama.
Your train is quite a peculiar model.
Where did you get it?
It's my dad.
He used to be an engine driver before the climate
catastrophe.
After everyone lost their jobs, he modified his train to
help with the family restaurant.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
That's very nice.
He retired?
What do you mean by retired?
Of course, I guess retirement doesn't exist in Outdom,
Japan.
My parents joined Mirai-do's recruitment program for dome
development.
The families of those who joined were offered asylum after
the works finished.
in a construction accident some weeks before they completed
the quota to qualify for asylum.
That's awful.
I'm sorry.
It was a long time ago.
I was basically still a baby.
I don't remember it very well.
My grandma told me never to get near a dome, but I don't
mind them.
I don't like to hold grudges from another era.
Thank you for the close-up sensor.
Yeah, I got you.
I see.
how did you manage to get in Japan I thought all inbound
traffic was heavily restricted after the catastrophe how did
you manage to reach Bepu ah this is a bit embarrassing I
come from a family of renowned diplomats from Peru I'd
rather not say too much about it I got into the dome city of
Osaka under the pretense of a cultural exchange but I snuck
out the moment I could my family is against my interests.
What interests?
Why?
Densha attack.
I love it so much.
I first came to Japan with my family when I was six.
We were docking in Yokohama and I saw a train convoy jump
over our ship.
It was the most exciting thing I'd seen in my short life.
It still is.
I want the whole world to know about it.
I'm sure it can change everything.
That's why I'm writing about it.
Huh?
Nepo baby!
I got another email about my visa recently.
They said nothing has changed.
So it's a good thing I didn't think that I was moving to
Japan.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for getting me into it.
Do you ever wonder what life is like inside the domes?
Have you ever visited a dome?
I wonder if the final boss is the person who jumped over the
ship.
That'd be sick!
No way, you need a dome citizen visa for that.
they say we the outsiders are contaminated we could put
everyone at risk inside the dome but I mean are we not
living normally I'm confused do they like live to be like 10
years old or something and are you huh what contaminated I
don't know I feel just fine but I was born after the
catastrophe new cafe is nice though yeah yeah I love my new
cafe maybe I'm a mutant you're out of this world at least
you ever wonder what life in the domes is like hmm yeah of
course we have an old computer at home and we can tune into
pirated broadcast I've seen their shows and music it all
looks really flashy hold on sorry my nose is itchy so bad
very sus the people outside the domes are contaminated by
dentsia tag.
They're contaminated by awesome.
Awesome sauce.
But I don't know if I'd trade it for the sky and the trees.
You're better off here.
Trust me.
Why doesn't he tell her what it's like?
I'm curious.
He went and saw.
Trick terminal.
We have some stuff here.
Oh, this one.
This one.
Oh, yeah, that's me.
Oh, oops.
Wait, I didn't mean to do that.
Oh, what the...
Oh, sorry.
I'm pressing B instead.
There we go.
Read at your own leisure, everybody.
Wait, is my head in the way?
My ahogue is a little bit.
Oh, I'm so so I see.
Yeah, they got that I'm so I see.
Oh, yeah.
Damn, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Let's keep going.
What time is it?
Sorry, I'm just checking the time.
Okay, we still got time before Vicky's birthday.
Vicky's birthday bash plus new outfit reveal.
and stuff
first try incoming oh yeah thanks Lyma she believes in me
pull a 10 trick combo collect 3 airport tickets chain 3
tricks in a single jump this game is so fun I'm more about
the vibes than getting it perfected but that's okay too
maybe We're here to go...
What is this weird place?
This is a derelict airport from the time before the
catastrophe.
I'll tell her.
What's an airport?
Whoa.
Before we were born, people used to travel in planes.
They were like trains that soared through the skies.
Whoa.
They don't have airplanes anymore?
love it are we going to get on a flying train planes were
banned after the climate collapse so no how does he know so
much anyway
this is the ideal place to practice with the Yao Yoro Zudo
the closest thing to being on a flying train okay I gotta do
the manual stuff I'll master the Yao Yoro Zudo so one day I
can fly further than those dusty old planes of That's the
spirit.
Nepo connections.
Perform tricks and build combos to maximize your score
before the two minute timer.
Reach the pass score to unlock the next track.
15,000?
Three, two, one, go!
Oh, 10,000.
Oh my gosh.
Whoa!
Uh...
Ah, dang it.
Alright, alright, alright, she says.
Oh, yeoy, yeoy.
Sweet!
Sweet, she says.
Oh, yeoy, yeoy.
Oh,
there we go.
Very good.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeoy, there's a little road.
What was it?
Oh.
No, I missed it!
There, there, there!
Very good.
There.
There was it.
There we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
How do I get back on it?
Yes, yes.
Do you hear how impressed Limu sounds?
Hell yeah.
Yeah.
They just appear.
Cool.
We are all impressed.
Are you now?
Oh my gosh, wait!
I don't have enough to pass though!
Let's go faster!
Let's go faster, yeah!
Uh-oh!
Oh, I just barely made it!
Overtime!
Oh!
I just barely made it!
Holy cow!
Good hope in Seyvels make me nervous.
after an airstomp.
What?
Oh, I didn't even see that one.
That one?
First try, though.
Yeah, we did first try.
Yahoo!
Let's go.
Laimu believed in me, and so I did it.
Thanks, Laimu.
Ready to go?
Yes.
I think so.
Lymo's got our backs.
Yeah, yeah.
Byonic, Yippa, welcome back.
Jesse, thank you for the five gift.
To quote the poets, it doesn't matter whether it's by an
inch or a mile.
Winning is winning.
So true.
Whoa, this place is crazy.
I'm here.
Have you come up with some new excuse to delay our match?
Emmy, you're so cute.
Don't worry.
I've spent all day getting ready just for you, and I spared
no expense.
I can't keep getting jump-scared, like, live who's appearing
at a VC or something.
Because she's so loud compared to everything else.
Come on.
I'll show you how glorious Dench attack can truly be.
Go!
Warm her up for me, girl.
Where are you going?
Come and face me.
I have to earn your audience with the Queen!
Who are you people?
Oh.
That was almost perfect, huh?
Time to get into the zone and ride the rainbow.
Yeah, where's the rainbow?
Oh.
I always forget to do tricks on...
Oops.
Whoops.
Oh.
On the...
It is?
We do?
Where are we seeing?
Oh, yo, yo.
Oh!
We saw the path.
Totally tanked it.
It's fine.
Oh, gosh.
Yes!
Sweet!
Whoa!
Is this the dome inside the dome?
Dun, dun.
Dashing Queen!
Unite!
whoa whoa oh wait are they gonna i was about to say are they
going to turn into like a mech oh my god they really did i
was too close wait oh i thought i was supposed to attack i'm
not just kidding
oh oh that's what i'm supposed to do got it oh
wait what What am I supposed to do here?
Charik!
Don't blow your guard, Eddie!
Maybe I break?
Oh, what?
Uh...
Trick over...
Oh, I have to trick over it.
Okay, I jump over it.
Charik!
Oh my gosh!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my...
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay!
I think I like hold too long sometimes for my...
Nice.
We're good.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
I was so close.
We gotta get our arms.
That's right.
I remember.
I tried.
You ruled.
Oh, oops.
Don't mock me, please.
There we go.
This is so...
Nice.
First try.
Oh, oops.
My bad.
That was bad.
It was so great.
Yeah.
Wait, did I get it?
Did I get her?
I think so.
Look!
Did I miss again?
Wait, I think I missed.
Oops.
Oopsie.
Very good.
Thank you.
First ride.
Oh, just okay.
Oh my gosh!
How's she doing all this with that puke training?
Girls, no time for glam.
We got every time for glam.
Oh my god.
Oops, oops.
Wait, accidentally.
Oh, there we go.
Incoming.
Oh, no.
Oh, I did it.
Way too, way too, way too slow.
That's okay, that's okay.
There we go.
There.
Nice, nice, nice.
Wee!
Wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee.
Sweet.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Oh my god, Rocket Punch!
Oh my god, I'm playing Metal Gear!
Metal Gear!
Oh wow!
Whoa!
Rocket Punch!
Oh shoot!
Oh dang it.
No way, it starts up at the beginning?
Okay.
Okay, I'm focused, I'm focused, I'm focused.
Okay, yep, real fun, real fun.
Yep, real fun, real fun.
Yeah!
Victory!
Yippee!
Results time!
Wait, I feel like I did so well, but it says not.
okay but i guess not such a lust for revenge a wins
a win so chill just so you know i put you in my tomodachi
live game oh thanks for having me there
thanks yoshi how is this possible are you really a newbie
yes yeah you're amazing
I've ever seen in my life.
Please, you need to teach me how to do all that.
But you just defeated me, M.E.U.
What could I possibly teach you?
You did great in my books.
Ah, thanks.
The first jump part probably hurt a bunch.
Oh, maybe.
Oh, yeah, probably it's because I died so much, huh?
You're so right.
The most scary part about getting all golds is no deaths in
the bosses.
Ah.
of I think I could do perfect this time after I after I
understood the patterns the first time I I cleared it easy
she's right Yoshi you're amazing I mean maybe a monster at
the basics but your style is unparalleled hmm that may be
true on our tiny tiny island but on the mainland Emmy will
be better off testing her might out there hmm let's go
together then you me huh Yes, aren't you dying to test
yourself against the other Densh attackers?
I am, but I have my gang here.
I need to take care of them.
This island is too small for your style, Yoshi.
Go out there and teach those man-land brutes the true
meaning of fashion.
Think about it.
I'm going to say goodbye to my grandma before we leave.
Meet us at the docks tomorrow if I feel like taking on the
world with us.
Bye.
Rivals to lovers.
Whoa!
Saying goodbye.
No!
I almost want to do it again, but it was seven minutes long.
I have 20 minutes.
Ready to go?
Oh, no, no, no.
Let's say goodbye.
Whoa.
What do you think, Grandma?
to your recipe grandma I may have found a place where I fit
in well it's not a place it's a people it's a people when
I'm around them I feel electric oh that's the power of the
training to leave this island with them she's in good hands
grandma i promise we'll take good care of emmy she's very
special but i'm sure you're well aware of that
what i wanted to meet whoever first sparked our rising star
barreled bug becomes the dentsia attacker of all time
chapter two the world opens up how many chapters are in this
game how long is it Miraido...
Good morning, everyone!
Good morning!
Did you know that the back train can take you to any major
city in Japan in under an hour?
No matter where you are?
Oh wait, we hate this guy.
This wondrous technology to visit Chugoku!
Your city of Hiroshima, full of history and...
Nine chapters, wow.
And good news?
The first areas to benefit from this project will be the
Totoori Sandus!
And the Otoyama Gardens!
Come to Chugoku.
Oh, it's not safe outside.
We don't like that guy.
We hate that guy.
We destroyed his statue and we're killing his domes.
Chugoku, here we come.
Huh.
Who's the boss around here?
Uh...
That'd be Dead Ball's leader, Madoka Sato.
The typhoon of Chugoku.
She's the reason I've never dared to leave the island.
We've clashed several times and Maroka's just too strong.
Yeah, we don't like the Bio Dome people.
We don't like Mirai Dome.
They killed Emi's parents.
We...
We killed...
They killed Emi's parents!
How can she be better?
Better than you!
Oh.
I wouldn't say better.
Her style pales in comparison to mine.
But she's tough as nails.
Don't make me more excited.
Let's go!
That's why.
Wall riding coast.
Cool.
First try incoming.
She knows it!
But Multi is so kawaii!
It's pretty cute.
I love me in mold.
Finger heel 180 over the broken bridge.
Okay, up and around.
To the right.
Up and around.
Whoop and boo.
I'm getting dizzy.
Ride all the billboards.
Rattle Madoka's billboard.
perform a trick after leaving a wall ride okay I'll try oh
my gosh he joins my seat wait that's so cute dead ball we
dead balling oh this place is horrendous everything's in
disrepair the dashing Queens take way better care of their
territory hmm is it that bad I think this looks fun it'll be
difficult to move around with so many missing tracks,
though.
You're right, and there's no lone rails around the grind on.
Wall rides.
This isn't my first Chugoku rodeo.
Come on, I'll teach you.
You dead ass right now.
I'm dead ball.
I'm dead balling.
I'm dead and I'm balling.
Call me dead balling.
Jump back to tracks when the wall...
Oh wait, switch the wall with left, then steer up and down.
Okay.
With up and down.
Here we go!
15 minute warning!
Thank you!
Oh.
Ow!
Oh, I forgot to do a trick.
Nice.
Oh.
Right!
Oh shoot.
Ow!
Oh my god.
What did I run into?
Wait, she's so cute.
Oh, come on.
Oh, I forgot to do one again.
Yeah, look at me.
Look at me.
Oh, shoot.
Wow.
Very good.
Thank you.
Oh, I tried to get onto the billboard, but...
Oh shoot, I missed that one.
Unless I got it.
Oh shoot.
Ah!
Guys, we made this game awesome.
Oh, oh, I can't read it.
I'm so sorry.
Thank you for the super chat!
Next time, try sending when I'm not, you know, mid-gaming.
Oh my gosh, I'm gonna die.
Nice, nice.
Nice.
Not quite the...
Yippee!
Yay!
Oh, I only got 3,000.
Dang it.
Timing was a catchy.
Yeah, I know.
I'm so sorry.
Ah, so close!
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
I forgot the finger heel.
I forgot it.
We...
I got a silver!
Let's go!
I sent that three videos to go out!
I could read it now though, I can read it now.
The guy who made this game also made male mole, which lets
you play as multi the mole.
If you want more cute mole action.
Oh, Kazuma, thank you!
I know, timing can be difficult for...
For Super Chats.
Especially when it's on delayed mode at the moment.
Because it's on normal latency.
Then my normal low latency.
Silver gaming in my first try.
I might be a gamer.
When I have Limeo backing me.
How can I not be a gamer, you know?
How can I not be?
Wait, hold on.
One second.
Oh.
Oh,
okay.
All right, we're good.
Stop right there.
Who do you think you are?
Riding all over our signs.
This is deadball's turf.
You'd better find another playground before you get hurt.
I challenge you!
What?
I'm going to beat you.
and then you'll be so impressed.
You'll take me to your leader and I'll beat her too.
I'm going to shut your mouth for good.
Come here.
Easy, Koyama.
I've got this.
The Sukupais.
Yeah, they're so cool.
Minto has an announcer win.
That'd be so cool.
What would I say?
I'd say hot dog.
And I'd say oi oi oi oi oi oi.
And I'd go say lots of things maybe see a doctor if you have
dead ball no they're yankees yeah they're so cool
choo-choo calabunga yeah we'd say calabunga choo-choo hi dog
yeah you're pretty good mooy mooy boo left right All the
minto noises.
Taking notes?
Come to Iwakuni and bring someone to take you to the
hospital afterwards.
But not for...
Wait, that's not how it works.
Wait, take you to the hospital, but...
Wait.
Call an ambulance.
But it's for you.
Kawabonga dude
Raiders of the dead ball Alright guys This might be our last
Track before we raid Raiders Then we will raid into Vicky
Fellow Densetsu member Her stream Wait let me make sure I
have it set up Okay wait We'll raid into her stream for her
birthday and her outfit.
Okay, do I do, I do.
Her outfit reveal and birthday.
Let's play.
Are you ready to go?
I am, Lai Mu.
I am.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
First try, first try, first try.
Now I want to watch Indiana Jones.
The sunflowers are so cute.
What is the catastrophe that happened?
Everything looks so good.
Huh, you didn't chicken out.
The name's Yasumi-ne.
I'm the one who will beat you today.
The rules are simple.
Try to keep up and don't die.
Be careful, I mean, Deadpool always plays dirty.
I'm sure they've laid out some kind of trap.
Really?
You don't think they've made something special just for me?
Thank you, Yasumi-ne.
You're welcome.
What's wrong with her?
You're in for a treat.
Let's go!
Two, one!
Hoia!
Oh, shoot.
I didn't.
Tehi-bu-hu.
Tehi-per-o.
Nailed it.
So true.
Nice.
You're good?
Oh, I'm good.
I'm good.
Oh, shoot.
I'm not good.
Nice.
Oh, ouch.
There we go.
Oh, right, right.
Oh, shoot.
There was a wall there.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
First try.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
What the?
Oh, my God.
Sweet.
I don't remember what the...
I didn't actually read what the things were.
for this.
We'll
get him there, time.
Yeah, we will.
So true.
Transfer, transfer.
Get the horn.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I got it.
Sweet.
Sweet, she says.
She loves me, I think.
Oh.
Holy cow.
I'm running!
Oh my gosh.
Yippee!
Oh shoot.
Dang it.
We're okay.
I think I have to double there.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Do I have to jump?
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, it's so fast.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
It's better to stay up then.
No, I was so close.
Oh, my score.
No, my score.
Sweet.
It's so fast.
Oh gosh.
Oh, we did it.
Let's go.
Oh, God.
No!
Where's my checkpoint?
Oh, shoot.
There we go.
We're batting.
Oh, wee!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
So close to it so far.
It could have been better.
I died quite a few times.
Whoopsie!
Escape the trap with a combo of at least 15.
Thanks for the coffee field crazy train!
Oh, Darko, thank you!
And with Lymo backing you up, it was one heck of a ride.
Thank you for the peace!
Thank you!
Next turn is for real.
No, Lai-Mu, that was for real.
That was the realist.
We still have a few minutes before she starts.
She's a beast.
How did she do that?
Wait, you know what they remind me of?
They remind me of like the...
the gangs and stuff in Blue Archive.
Thanks for all the noises!
Let's get Vicky a really happy birthday!
We will!
Soon, soon, soon, soon.
I want a dweller.
Me too.
What's your name?
Emmy Araki.
I am Yui Koyama.
You got our girls all riled up.
Do you think you can race them all?
I'd love that.
Come to the abandoned racetrack in Minai tomorrow.
I'll say everything else.
Yeah, like the helmet gang and stuff, don't they?
Kind of remind you.
They do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, we have a new fanzine.
Fernando, welcome back.
You know me?
Yes, all pretty cool units are connected to an independent
network.
Requests for your fanzine on the dashing queens come in all
the time.
Superb work.
Really?
How's I'm expecting that?
It makes me so happy to hear.
Are you working on something about Dead Ball now?
Mm-hmm.
That's right.
They have a really powerful energy.
Let's see if I can do them justice.
They're scary.
I hope you come out of it unscathed.
Anyway, it'll be a pleasure to upload and print your zines
here.
Thank you.
I like Puri-kun.
Oh, Yasumina.
She's so cool.
Oh, this one too.
Nice.
Let's add in these as well.
Yes.
So far.
I don't...
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to do that.
Oh, it shows you how many you've completed.
Cool.
There were some here that we had not finished yet.
And then...
Oh, whoops.
Cute!
I have to get better scores, I'm assuming, so that I can...
Wait.
Oh, there it is.
We finished the whole page!
Let's go!
Yeah, maybe I gotta clear more challenges and dares and
stuff so that we can get Kay the queen of comic kit.
Wait, where do you see that?
Guys, I'm at comic kit this year.
Crazy.
Oh, it's the film reels.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
This game is awesome, isn't it?
Check the sticker shop.
I want to see.
What, the garage?
Wait.
Oh, no.
The sticker shop.
Here, right?
Yes.
Oh, yes.
I think we only had her before, no?
Now we have all three of them.
Oh, oops.
Wait, I didn't mean to buy it, but that's fine.
I'll buy all of them.
Why not?
why not why not let's just buy him this one's really cute i
like this one a lot
this one is still unlocked though curious curious curious
i've had i had so much fun with dinch attack we should
definitely pick it up again sometime um yeah we got that
lime move sticker though wait who else is in the game
I think once we get to this next castle over there in the
corner we'll be able to unlock some more more dents
attacking yeah yeah yeah oh iron mouse is in it too see dog
Rin Penrose oh I want the others as well hmm I want the
others too is Is everybody just a code?
I want Mousy.
Yiga Shiori Iris.
Cool, cool, cool, cool.
Wait there's so many people I didn't even realize.
I knew Lymo.
I think I...
I think I knew Shiori and Iris.
It's only cheat codes.
Oh, cool!
I think actually I knew Giga also.
But I didn't know anybody else.
Cool, cool, cool.
Well, we'll get them next time.
Let me see if Vicky is live yet.
And we will head over.
This game is such a vibe.
I want the...
Oh, she's not live yet.
I want the soundtrack.
Fake me!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Iron Mouse is also on the soundtrack.
Wait, really?
Wait, I guess we...
If we have time, how do I get the other...
How do I get the other...
Other ones?
I want them.
The other skins.
oh she just went live oh my gosh what timing well guys
awesome we're gonna raid into Vicky's new outfit and her
birthday so make sure you wish Vicky a super duper happy
birthday and stick around for her new outfit because it's so
so cute and yeah thank you guys so much for dentsha
attacking with me it was so fun it was So fun!
Yay!
Ochu Minto everybody!
Otu Minto!
Have a good day!
Have a good night!
Have a good time zone!
Otu Minto!
Itta Rashaay!
Bye bye everyone!
Bye bye!
Thank you so much!
See you!
Bye bye!
It was so fun listening and watching!
Thanks, Bain!
Thank you so much!
Bye bye!
Wow!